y siguen las protestas en europa cerca
de 35 mil personas salieron a las calles
de bruselas para protestar en contra de
las restricciones del cobi 19 impuestas
por el gobierno para combatir la
reciente oleada del virus entre bombas
de humo cañones de agua y fuegos
artificiales hubo enfrentamientos entre
los manifestantes y la policía el
miércoles bélgica endureció las
restricciones pidiéndole a sus
ciudadanos el uso de la mascarilla con
mayor frecuencia e imponiendo una medida
de trabajo desde casa los locales
comerciales nocturnos pedirán pruebas
negativas del virus para que sus
clientes puedan bailar sin mascarilla
hasta este domingo bélgica registró 26
mil 568 muertes totales por coronavirus
con más de 1.500.000 casos totales desde
el inicio de la pandemia
en países bajos el panorama es muy
similar por segunda noche consecutiva
los manifestantes salieron a expresar su
descontento el enojo de las personas
dejó un saldo de 5 agentes de policía
heridos y vehículos incendiados mientras
la policía intentaba contenerlos con
perros cañones de agua y persecuciones a
caballo según un comunicado tres
personas que fueron impactadas por balas
de la policía siguen hospitalizadas en
países bajos este fin de semana se
presentaron manifestaciones en rotterdam
la haya y ámsterdam la organización
mundial de la salud dijo la semana
pasada que europa era el punto de
concentración de la pandemia en estos
momentos siendo la única región en la
que estaban aumentando las muertes por
kobe 19